on connaît mieux les jardins ouvriers
que les jardins communautaires ces
derniers sont nombreux à new york en
france il existe depuis seulement 3 4
ans le principe est simple un terrain en
friche et confiée aux habitants d'un
quartier l'activité des temps mais elle
a également le mérite de favoriser les
rencontres entre voisins cultiver son
jardin devient alors un jeu d'enfant and
sylvain patrice brugger je suis d'un
quartier plutôt populaire je ne pique
pas je suis même assez ouvert peut
entrer qu'il veut mais faut quand même
montrer patte blanche
vous ne voyez toujours pas je suis ce
qu'on appelle un jardin communautaire
je vous présente quelques membres de ma
tribu la grenouille l'araignée quand
elle veut bien se montrer
et puis s'il y a eu bien sûr les
habitants du quartier ils disent que je
suis leur petite musique leur façon
d'apprendre à se parler tout simplement
trop loin dans le mag vous avez vu c'est
vous seul numéro jardin pour rencontrer
ses voisins elle c'est jeanine lé
vanille et ça peut être bien dans la vie
elle est infirmière
ici on l'appelle la concierge parce
qu'il est toujours là pour tout le monde
et qu'elle est pas la dernière à donner
un coup de main c'est sûr j'appartiens
toujours à la mairie mais en fait je
suis son bébé avec les autres c'est elle
qui m'a conçu il ya trois ans quand je
travaille de nuit qui
assez dur quand même jardaa me détend et
me déstresse énormément j'en ai besoin
toute façon là je suis au grand air je
discute avec énormément de gens parce
qu'on a toujours des visites des amis
qui viennent on en a fait quelque chose
à partager à se raconter et c'est
vraiment une détente le jardinage
voici jérôme la science l'animateur
d'après lui je n'ai rien d'un jardin
ouvrier pas même d'un petit lopin
familial puis communautaires en france
ont commencé à se multiplier tout droit
arrivés des etats-unis
aux états unis il ya l'aspect ethnique
et fort parce que c'est propre mais rica
en france on recherche pas du tout ça la
communauté c'est une communauté
d'habitants de proximité ou même
l'habitant dans un cas on les accepte
on est ouvert on essaye d'être ouvert à
tous voilà donc c'est des jardins
communautaires ouverts et néanmoins
clôturés
ici tout le monde peut avoir la clé et
ça continue à arriver
c'est comme ça toute la journée ceux là
sont des artistes
je crois qu'ils ont des idées juste un
peu étrange pour moi on a des petits
projets comme des vidéos des on a des
aussi des performances mois sans doute
faire et si c'est à dire des happenings
des choses qui se passent sur le site
hier encore je n'étais qu'une friche
abandonné aujourd'hui la mairie ils
disent que je fabrique du lien social -
10 seulement faut jamais s'asseoir sur
ses lauriers